the headlines say that former president
trump was exonerated and violently
clearing out protesters for a photo op
at lafayette square last year those
headlines are wrong first of all this
report was incredibly narrow it looked
only to the actions of the u.s park
police it didn't look to the secret
service it didn't interview
attorney general william barr it didn't
talk about all of the bureau of prisons
officers who were in lafayette square
that day and second of all the facts
that are in this report are actually
incredibly damning if you actually read
the report
it does appear that the u.s park police
had a plan to clear protesters in order
to put up a fence
however the us park police had no idea
the president was going to be on site
until bill barr
came out informed them to which the park
police was incredulous
then minutes later before the park
police could even implement their plan
to give warnings to the protesters the
u.s secret service jumped the gun
and started violently attacking the
protesters on site and on top of that
the us park police were not authorized
to use cs gas and pepper balls which the
secret service
and the bureau of prisons employees were
actually using
there was much more to the story and
this is not an exoneration this still
appears to be exactly what it looks like